bonjour à toutes et à tous ces clichés
or not piché l'émission sur les clichés
qui certes a des bonnes que les clichés
en biologie évolutive et aujourd'hui on
s'attaque à la question l'homme
évolue-t-il encore bien sûr que non il
évolue plus puisque avec tous les
progrès de la médecine et tout ça eh ben
il ya plus de sélection naturelle petit
lit n'importe quoi bien sûr qu'ils
évoluent rien le don de sagesse on a
moins en moins bien oui toi aussi
hinault petit orteil là ils sont en
train de disparaître et puis notera
parmi ceux ci
alors bien sûr qu'on évolue au
restaurent alors évidemment ça c'est la
réponse que tout le monde donne oui
l'homme évolue toujours pas ce qu'on
constate la réduction de certains
organes locaux les dents de sagesse
évidemment qu'ils ne sont même plus là
derrière chez certaines personnes
l'appendice qui se réduit encore plus et
le petit orteil et liens de plus en plus
de lui et ça c'est une idée qui vient en
fait de tendance évolutive convoi dans
dans le registre fossile de l'évolution
humaine
on constate la réduction du petit orteil
parce que le petit orteil devient de
moins en moins important dans la marche
on constate aussi la baisse de la
fréquence de la présence de la norme
sagesse mais il faut pas perdre de vue
qu'il ne s'agit que de tendance
évolutive il s'agit de grandes lignes de
l'évolution humaine qui comporte d'état
d'exception est l'une des tendances
évolutives les plus connus dans
l'évolution humaine c'est l'augmentation
de la taille du cerveau donc on constate
une augmentation de la taille du cerveau
depuis les australopithèques jusqu'à
l'homme moderne
oui mais il ya des exceptions il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'exceptions on a au
monal est dit on à homo floresiensis qui
ont tous les deux des cerveaux
relativement petit et on sait désormais
qu'il s'agit de véritables réduction de
la taille du cerveau et pas seulement de
le fait d'avoir conservé un petit
cerveau de façon primitif c'est pas une
absence d'évolution du cerveau en fait
c'est à cerveau qui est devenu gros et
qui est devenu plus petit chez homo
naledi et homo floresiensis et même chez
homo sa place on constate une réduction
de la taille du cerveau puisque les homo
sapiens archaïque avait un cerveau qui
était en moyenne un petit peu plus gros
que les homo sapiens moderne donc dire
que l'homme évolue toujours c'est la
bonne réponse effectivement par contre
dire que ces tendances évolutives en
sont la preuve
c'est faux parce que en réalité
l'évolution est complètement
imprévisible on ne sait pas dans quelle
direction l'évolution valait donc on ne
sait pas si on va finir
perdre nos dents de sagesse un jour je
sais pas si on va perdre la petite
taille nous voilà donc partis car il va
rester et comme le premier protagoniste
l'a souligné c'est vrai que la sélection
naturelle a tendance à perdre de son
importance par exemple sur les dents de
sagesse maintenant vu qu'on les retire
de toute façon il n'ya plus tellement de
sélection sur les dents de sagesse
mais avant de partir sur un débat sur
les dents de sagesse avec votre
interlocuteur
on va s'arrêter sur l'affirmation qui
pose réellement problème et c'est celle
qui consiste à dire que la médecine
seraient responsables d'une baisse de la
sélection naturelle
et là c'est un problème parce que la
médecine est effectivement responsable
d'une baisse de la sélection naturelle
dans nos pays développés donc scellé en
europe l'amérique du nord le japon
doublé mais par contre pour ce qui est
des pays qui sont en voie de
développement c'est un peu différent
parce que là la médecine n'a pas la même
utilisation que ouais là là où toi tu
plonges le doigt dans le gange
es tu pour ea sur pattes il ya des gens
qui la boivent l'eau du gange et tu vas
pas me dire que chez eux il n'y a pas de
sélection naturelle qui s'opère et puis
il ya aussi le taux de mortalité
infantile
tu vas voir un énorme effet dans une
protection et puis les progrès de la
médecine n'arrête pas la dérive
génétique et oui parce que tant que vous
aurez les populations qui sont un tant
soit peu isolé si population donc se
reproduire entre elles et pouvoir
développer une nouvelle aile de nouveaux
gènes
bref évoluer dans leur cour exactement
et vous pourriez rétorqué qu' il ya les
voyages et que les voyages ça va mixer
tout ce beau monde
oh ouais mais en fait encore une fois
tout le monde ne peut pas voyager les
gens des pays développés peuvent voyager
mais est ce que les gens aient payé le
prix en forcément envie de se reproduire
avec d'autres personnes ne sont pas
forcément de chez eux
et si un choix du partenaire exactement
donc la dérive génétique elle a encore
lieu et elle est facteur d'évolution
chez l'espèce humaine donc déjà pour
bien pouvoir répondre à la question il
faut abandonner ce point de vue
occidental au centre et c'est à dire
centré sur la civilisation occidentale
tout le monde n'est pas au même niveau
du point de vue médecine et du point de
vue voyage et donc la sélection
naturelle et la dérive génétique sont
encore des réalités dans notre monde et
il n'y a pas forcément besoin d'aller
dans le fin fond de la sibérie au fin
fond de la jungle
ionienne pour continuer à constater ces
phénomènes évolutif
mais bon alors tout ça c'est bien joli
mais du coup c'est quoi la raison il ya
le fait que l'homme évolue toujours à
donc c'est quoi la bonne réponse est
donc la bonne réponse c'est bien que
l'homme évolue mais la vraie raison pour
laquelle l'homme évolue et en fait il y
en a trois à trois bonnes raisons pour
laquelle l'homme évolue toujours et pour
laquelle on peut affirmer on peut se
permettre d'être complètement affirmatif
sur le fait que les êtres humains évolue
toujours pour que l'être humain évolue
absolument plus il faudrait les numéros
qu'il échappe à 100% à la descendance
avec modification donc il faudrait qu'il
n'y ait plus aucune mutation entre les
générations d'êtres humains et ça le
seul moyen d'y arriver c'est le clonage
globalement et ça on sait pas faire le
clonage encore en tout cas pas
naturellement
et on connaît des organismes qui se
reproduisent par clonage qu'ils
n'échappent pas à l'évolution qui
continue d'évoluer malgré tout donc il
faudrait un clonage
absolument mais rigoureusement parfait
aucune cette raison numéro il faudrait
que l'homme échappe totalement à la
sélection naturelle
et pour y arriver il ya pas 36 façons de
le faire faudrait qu'on meurt tous
complètement par hasard au pif jeter un
dé et paf si vous tombez sur six vous
n'êtes pas ou alors il faudrait qu'on ne
meurt plus du tout mais sans se
reproduire parcouru alors immortalité
alimente alité c'est pas pour tout de
suite
raison numéro 3 il faudrait une
condition de pande nikci totale et
globale sur toute l'humanité alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la pandémie
ksiba ça veut dire qu'en gros pour
simplifier tout le monde est capable de
coucher avec tout le monde partout sur
le globe afin que la population humaine
globale forment une seule unité
génétique et qu' aucune sous-espèce ou
embranchements puisse bourgeonner de cet
énorme population mondiale et devenir
une nouvelle espèce camp alors dit comme
ça ça fait un peu ans j'y vois là c'est
totalement sas et voilà mais en gros
l'idée derrière ça c'est que vous auriez
autant de chances de vous reproduire
avec quelqu'un qui vit
au plein milieu de la forêt amazonienne
qui a rigolé voisine c'est ça il faudra
exactement la même probabilité pour vous
de vous reproduire avec votre voisin d'à
côté qu'avec quelqu'un qui vit en
amazonie là maintenant tout de suite
c'est à dire que là où vous êtes assis
là maintenant devant votre ordinateur en
train de regarder cette vidéo vous
auriez autant de probabilités dans la
prochaine minutes c'est avoir une
relation sexuelle avec la voisine où le
voisin et chaîne 10 minutes ont
d'ailleurs échappé on n'est pas à ça
près et avec un papou de nouvelle guinée
ou avec quelqu'un en amazonie voilà
c'est la téléportation quoi ça implique
de la téléportation totalement en
conclusion l'être humain qui n'évolue
pas ou qu'ils n'évoluent plus c'est une
absurdité c'est une aberration
biologique une impossibilité biologique
tout simplement parce qu'on ne peut pas
empêcher les mutations de se produire on
ne peut pas empêcher la sélection
naturelle de se produire même avec
beaucoup de médecine et on ne peut pas
permettre un flux génétiques aléatoires
et globale de toute l'humanité
à chaque instant de chaque époque c'est
juste impossible
on ne peut pas y arriver donc oui
l'homme évolue et de toute façon on ne
peut pas l'empêcher d'évoluer donc est
ce que l'homme continue d'évoluer et oui
oui mais ce que nous donne sagesse ont
quelque chose à voir là dedans sinon
voilà c'était cliché en cliché on vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi et on vous dis
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos
car oui
[Musique]